DISCOURSE.
WELL, TODAY, SENATE MINORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL REJECTED
IT.
>> WELL, LET ME GIVE YOU MY VIEW
WHAT HAPPENED JANUARY 6th.
WE'RE ALL HERE.
WE'RE HERE.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED.
IT WAS A VIOLENT INSURRECTION
FOR THE PURPOSE OF TRYING TO
PREVENT THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER AFTER A LEGITIMATELY
CERTIFIED ELECTION FROM ONE
ADMINISTRATION TO THE NEXT
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS.
>> THAT'S WHAT IT WAS.
LOUD, CLEAR, SAYING IT, THE
TRUTH.
McCONNELL ALSO SAID IT IS NOT
THE JOB OF THE RNC TO PICK AND
CHOOSE WHICH REPUBLICANS IT
SUPPORTS.
WELL, COMPARE THAT TO THE HOUSE
GOP CONFERENCE CHAIR TODAY WHO
DEFENDED THE CENSURE RESOLUTION
AND REFUSED TO CALL OUT THE RNC
TO USING THE WORDS LEGITIMATE
POLITICAL DISCOURSE WITH THIS
DEFENSE.
>> YOU THIS I THAT JANUARY 6th
WAS LEGITIMATE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE, THE RNC OVER THE
WEEKEND?
>> AS REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN VERY
CLEAR, WE CONDEMN THE VIOLENCE
JANUARY 6th AND THE VIOLENCE ON
2020 AS VIOLENT CRIMINALS
ATTACKED FEDERAL BUILDINGS,
INCLUDING PARTS OF WASHINGTON,
D.C.
SO WE HAVE BEEN CLEAR IN THAT
CONDEMNATION.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS DID NOT CONDEMN
THE VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENED ALL
OF 2020.
>> NOW CNN SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT
AND JOHN AVALON, SENIOR ANALYST
AND AUTHOR OF THE NEW BACK,
LINCOLN AND THE FIGHT FOR PEACE,
OUT ONE WEEK FROM TODAY.
EXCEPT I ALREADY HAVE A COPY.
I HOPE EVERYONE WILL GO THERE.
JOHN, SENATOR McCONNELL CALLS IT
WHAT IT WAS, LET'S GIVE IT THE
CREDIT TODAY, A VIOLENT
INSURRECTION, SOME HOW SAYING
THIS AT THIS POINT MORE THAN A
YEAR LATER IS HARD AND
CONTROVERSIAL, IN FACT,
IMPOSSIBLEN FOR MANY ELECTED
REPUBLICANS.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE TO STRUGGLE
TO UNDERSTAND WHY, JOHN.
>> IT'S A CHOICE.
LET'S NOT, YOU KNOW, MAKE IT ANY
MORE DIFFICULT THAN IT IS, THESE
ARE GROWN ADULTS, ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES.
MITCH McCONNELL SAID THE TRUTH.
IT WAS A VIOLENT INSURRECTION TO
STOP A PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER.
THE DECISION TO HIDE BEHIND THE
WHAT ABOUTISMS OR DEFENDING THE
BASE OR FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS SOME MIX OF SPINELESSNESS AND
CAREER-I
CAREER-ISM.
IT'S COMPLETELY CLEAR OF REALITY
AND FACT.
THEY MAY MAKE SHORT-TERM
POLITICS.
IT WILL LOOK LIKE HELL IN THE
EYES OF HISTORY.
>> MANU RAJU WAS ON CAPITOL HILL
AND HE TALKED TO KEVIN McCARTHY,
TOO.
I WANTED TO PLAY THAT EXCHANGE.
>> Reporter: I REFER TO JANUARY
6th AS POLITICAL DISCOURSE?
>> THAT'S NOT CORRECT.
THE RNC WERE TALKING ABOUT
EVERYBODY KNOWS, ANYBODY WHO HAS
BROKEN, ANY DAMAGE THAT WILL
CALL FOR THOSE PEOPLE AS WE SAID
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING SHOULD
BE IN JAIL.
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT THE SIX RNC
MEMBER WHO'S JANUARY 6th HAS
SUSPEND WHO WEREN'T EVEN HERE
AND WERE IN FLORIDA THAT DAY.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, IT'S
INTERESTING McCARTHY WENT TO
SUCH A LEVEL OF DETAIL WHAT THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S GOOD HE DID.
THE RESOLUTION SAYS
REPRESENTATIVES KINZINGER ARE
PARTICIPATING IN PERSECUTION OF
ORDINARY CITIZENS ENGAGED IN
POLITICAL DISCOURSE, NOT TALKING
ABOUT JANUARY 6th IN FLORIDA
THAT DAY.
WHAT IS McCARTHY DOING HERE?
DID HE JUST MAKE SOMETHING UP?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
BUT HERE'S WHAT I DO KNOW.
LIZ CHENEY AND ADAM KINZINGER
DRIVE KEVIN McCARTHY CRAZY, DAY
IN AND DAY OUT.
AND THE FACT THAT HE DID NOT
MAKE THIS REPUBLICANS ON THE
COMMITTEE WHO WOULD BE
ACCEPTABLE, I THINK ALSO MAKES
HIM CRAZY DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
BECAUSE HE DOES NOT KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES.
KEVIN McCARTHY, UNLIKE MITCH
McCONNELL, FINALLY MITCH
McCONNELL, BUT KEVIN McCARTHY IS
STILL PLAYING TO AN AUDIENCE OF
ONE.
DONALD TRUMP.
HE WANTS TO BE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE IF REPUBLICANS WHEN IN THE
FALL AND EVERYTHING ELSE FALLS
BY THE WAYSIDE.
THAT IS HIS GOAL.
>> JOHN, YOU KNOW WHAT'S AMAZING
IS LEGITIMATE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE, CALLING WRITERS
DISCOURSE IS HARDER TO CALL OUT
ACTUALLY
THAN THE CENSURE, THERE ARE
REPUBLICANS COMING TO THE
DEFENSE SAYING IT IS A BAD IDEA
FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY TO BE
CENSUREING THEM.
HERE ARE THREE REPUBLICANS.
>> I THINK THE WAY IN LIKE THIS
IS INVOKE IT AND FRANKLY NOT
VERY CONSTRUCTIVE EITHER.
>> I THINK THAT WE AS A PARTY
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT PEOPLE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE ECONOMY,
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
CONTINUING STRUGGLES WITH COVID,
THEY'RE LOOKING AHEAD AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT US TO DO.
>> ANYTHING THAT MY PARTY DOES
THAT COMES ACROSS AS BEING
STUPID IS NOT GOING TO HELP US.
>> SO JUST TO BE CLEAR, ROMNEY,
OKAY, WE EXPECT HIM.
BUT THE OTHER SENATORS NOT SO
MUCH.
YOU ARE SEEING PEOPLE THAT
BEFORE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING THAT
ARE SAYING, HEY, LOOK, THIS
CENSURE IDEA IS A BAD IDEA.
DO YOU SEE GROWING REPUBLICAN
SENATORS SPEAKING OUT HERE?
IS THIS SOMETHING OR NOT?
>> I THINK IT'S THE BEGINNING OF
SEEING THE CULT START TO CRACK.
YOU ARE SEEING IN THE WAKE OF
MIKE PENCE FRIDAY NIGHT CALLING
OUT TRUMP FINALLY IN CLEAR
TERMS.
YOU'VE SEEN YOU KNOW PEOPLE LIKE
LARRY HOGAN AND CHRIS CHRISTY
SPEAKING OUT EVEN MORE CLEARLY.
NOW THESE SENATORS, NOT JUST
MITT ROMNEY AND BILL CASSIDY,
THOSE THAT GO OUT AND
RATIONALIZE HIM IN THE PAST
SAYING THIS IS TOO FAR.
AND YOU KNOW THE OLD SAYING ONE
MAN WITH COURAGE MAKES A
MAJORITY.
WELL, SIX SENATORS START TO SEND
FORTH RIPPLES OF HOPE FOR MAYBE
SOME OF THEIR COLLEAGUES SAYING,
YOU KNOW WHAT, MAYBE TELLING THE
TRUTH ISN'T THE END OF THE
WORLD.
MAYBE IT'S THE SMART POLITICAL
THING TO DO.
>> AND LET'S HOPE WE DO.
OF COURSE, JAMIE, THERE ARE
REPUBLICANS, THOUGH, THAT ARE
OPEN ABOUT MAKING CRUSHING
CHENEY AS THEIR NUMBER ONE GOAL.
SHE IS RUNNING FOR ELECTION.
MARRIAGERY TAYLOR GREENS THE
ONLY THING IS MAKING SURE CHENEY
LOSES.
>> THAT'S PRIORITY NUMBER ONE TO
ME, IT'S ONE THING, WE CAN PLAY
SMALL BALL, THAT'S KICKING LIZ
CHENEY AND ADAM KINSINGER OUT OF
OUR CONFERENCE, WHICH I WANT TO
DO.
I WANT TO FINISH THE GAME, I
WANT THE "W" THAT MEANS
DEFEATING LIZ CHENEY AND MAKING
SURE SHE NEVER COMES PACK.
>> IS CONGRESSMAN CHENEY
CONCERNED?
IS SHE WORRIED ABOUT HER
SITUATION?
>> SO, LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT
MARRIAGERY TAYLOR GREEN FOR A
MINUTE.
I DON'T THINK LIZ CHENEY IS
SCARED OF ANYONE, I CERTAINLY
DON'T THINK MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREEN.
CHENEY HAS SAID ALL ALONG THAT
THIS IS ABOUT DEMOCRACY, THE
CONSTITUTION, RULE OF LAW,
POLITICS.
SHE KNOWS SHE HAS A TOUGH BATTLE
IN WYOMING.
WYOMING IS THE TRUMPIEST STATE
THERE IS.
MORE PEOPLE VOTED FOR TRUMP THAN
FOR LIZ CHENEY.
NOT A LOT BUT MORE.
I THINK THAT LIZ CHENEY HAS MADE
IT CLEAR SHE'S PUT THIS ON THE
LINE, EVERY DAY SHE DOUBLES
DOWN.
WHETHER SHE WINS OR NOT, SHE'S
NOT GOING AWAY.
AND SHE SEES THIS AS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN ANY POLITICAL